I always thought all for doing this for
other people so that I don't have many
people in my videos so morning I'm gonna
reload a little bit so hi guys today I
am here with two very special girls
these are the girls I have been working
with to produce the sleep paralysis game
the Google VR game named girls so this
is Tabitha hello what do you like about
gaming and being a game dev phone
alright - three models she was a three
character mode yeah yeah I'm interested
and then this is Tiffany so I call that
concept up below so my divot Ward's for
3d not necessary characters are like up
to the hybrid I am the coder so we work
pretty well as a team because I was the
game designer and then we had the
character modeler and the environment
modeler and we all enjoy a bit of
drawing as well so we could all pitch in
on that which is nice yeah I just
figured since our deadline is up I am
still going to be working on the game to
release it to you guys and make it a bit
better but deadlines in University is
over we are currently studying computer
game art and I just wanted to talk to
you guys a bit about us making games
anything's because this is about as bad
so she's that word why did you guys get
into gaming and why did you want to make
games why did you come to university I
got into gaming when I was about three
and I used to play a nintendo64 with my
dad and then that kind of progressed on
to playing PC games I think it was like
five or six insane
Unreal Tournament and then that
progressed on playing Sims
I started making content systems - so
involved textures and stuff and then I
kind of realized your kids make a career
out of it so yeah I'm going to study it
up easy
sweet'n yeah yeah when I was problem I
was sat in my
that slap like [ __ ] the whole time he
is into gaming lots and I watch and play
tomb raider and that was really the
first game that absolutely adored
everything so I just was all games all I
did really that made me want to like get
in the game but what I realized was that
gaming is completely different to making
a game there is a lot to it it's not as
simple as people think but I still
enjoyed that nonetheless like more I do
the more I understand so yeah I loved
the way they looked I was like wow
absolutely speechless sounds like how do
people make these and that's why I was
like I really wanna make on let me do it
and obviously but how do I enter here
yeah well we've made two games together
now haven't we in two separate groups
the last game was the major one no the
last game was a super a versus one which
I definitely want to share with you guys
and that took us three months yeah
making a game in that time it's
stressful and you don't get it finished
like there's no way you can get a game
finished within three months especially
with three people
yeah when you're making game usually
have a game designer so what the game
designer is is someone who comes up with
the narrative or the reason behind the
game year the reasons for things and
also the platform or the technical bits
but also they coach the game at the end
as well as they play into unity so all
the code together which is like what I
absolutely adore and then it's basically
told you guys what to do than I do this
yeah I don't know I didn't I think I
love matter hopefully I don't know isn't
that something other people's games we
heard it works out doesn't it yeah yeah
I think the main thing about making a
game I guess like anything team work is
in the biggest the biggest thing and I
think that's what I've learnt the most
irony through this whole course it's
just communication is it doesn't matter
how good you are
who's the best in the team it's not
about that if you're worried about who's
doing better work then your overall game
is going to be pants yeah for sure you
be stressing it I think it helped that
we get on so well like we respect each
other like we don't think it could get
much done free time yeah yeah it's not a
competition for it we're just really
excited like what how it's going to look
how it unites Conte and
that was fun yeah exactly I think that's
also why I want to make games as well
because the whole aspect of like making
something that you can interact with and
then seeing it and interacting with it
is just so exciting you can make a film
and then what's your act is like when
you make a game and then you see like
other people play it and you see how
they interact with it and then they do
things that you haven't even thought of
doing in the game that you created
yourself it's so interesting yeah I
think it's amazing how it's like nothing
and then it never comes figure I think
yeah I thought really gets me I think
yeah especially with you guys because
you spend so long making models oh yeah
and then to see what that ends up being
well I know that into unity must be like
a bit weird the bigger reason I think
and when you make a game or for me it is
yes you want when it all comes together
yeah and a miracle I think we did really
well yes me too yeah I'm super happy
with it I love being game designer
because I get like I get control like
everything together the end and I get
all your assets and then I think that's
when like the creativity sparks and I'm
like I could put this piece of code here
to do that and that's why timings really
a big deal for me anyway so I was always
giving them load of deadlines yeah yeah
I was like can I have this by this day I
always asked you if you could do it in
time it wasn't usually like to just at
that time you know oh yeah that was a
loose line the thing is if I got stuff
back from you and put it in the game
that gave me time to like realize what
worked what didn't work what extra code
I could maybe add and then if we had
more time and maybe we could add new
features into the game deadlines are
just a major thing anyway because he'll
do just get lost in the swamp of work if
you don't have a deadline I don't have a
structure of what to work on first and
then want to move on to next and what
did you find most difficult about making
like a game I mean I mean it was very
tedious to be honest the animations I've
never explored animations
like performance like the whole
highlight processes animations self
confusing I would like to study that a
bit more tonight yeah the thing is in
our course because there's so much to do
with making a game Josh you teach you it
look like go and find a youtube video
this is the reason to cover right in
Antonio
yeah maybe give me one lesson on when
you're like making something with in
time screw trying to do it yourself and
being like I want to say that I've done
at my family if there are assets out
there readily available and pieces of
code and snippets like that's use them
and also you can learn from that anyway
so you can pick it apart and be like why
is this working oh they you literally
did that and that's how you learn I
think anyway yeah have you ever had like
an experience before going into this
industry for getting you to work in this
industry or during university where you
feel like being a girl has movie
hindered or the opposite helps a little
bit not as like being at uni search but
I just play a game for mine I've
experienced people being horrible
towards me because I am a girl I'm glad
yeah okay around the whole time online
is the most of experience like
experience people being horrible to me
like I got targeted on purpose all of
them female so I deleted it in young
because I said that was it so yeah
that's probably the world of experience
do then I get people when I meet people
from that nights out and stuff and they
ask me why I'm studying at uni and they
don't believe me that I'm studying what
computer game arts they just don't
believe me they actually don't but they
don't really feel like I have to get my
student ID out to sorry with really yes
it's half what I really found really
yeah well I don't know and then they get
this is cool I bet like you it would be
ideal girlfriend too
yes a way that ah no the worst I had it
was like oh no you look like someone
that just like fashion or something oh
yeah I gather all the time the like you
don't know how to code no oh I don't
understand the whole phrase you looks
like you should it's like what yeah why
just it is my brain is my brain need of
them have to look a certain way you can
be into so many different things yet
still you know enjoy gaming and making a
game like I love my makeup I like going
online you do get funny looks people do
judge a bit should you really be you
know making a game which is annoying but
can you do
it's weird I feel like gaming is
evolving to it a date where games are
like in the same realm this film now and
I do believe honestly in the next like
five to ten years or maybe less
if no one will say do you play games it
will just be a matter of like everyone
plays games will be talking about just
like everyone watched films like what
are you talking about it's more about
what kind of games do you play your
mobile gamer are you a console gamer do
you like horror do you like action you
know just like film so did you like long
calms you yeah so I think it's becoming
more like that I know I don't think
really the stigma is it's definitely
going away I think you just have those
two people at least holding away yeah
yeah some people you meet though like
wow yeah I think it's cool but yeah I
got so insulted from people oh you don't
look like the person on one let me fight
you in again I am people ask me like why
do you think that girls don't want to be
in tech or there aren't as many girls in
the tech industry and I guess this
extends beyond just gaming but what why
your views are now do you think I think
it might be right inside intimidating
because it is associated with males and
for a woman to go into something like I
can be a bit scary when we link class
possibly Riley I don't know why its
associated with male iron Factory I let
go
Gaming like I guess games originally
were developed like men but there was no
like they want aiming at men I think
it's like intimidation I don't know I
think people just stuck on the way or
thinking and like generate like back
then and some people always hold on
tight you you will never get someone
who's just so open-minded everyone has
their thoughts and opinions and people
should open up to it you can't force
anyone currently it's very strange
because what you say I'd be intimidating
you're in a computer game at school so
you're obviously not that intimidated by
it intimidates me though it is cool yeah
it was only a fast day and when we met
thank God another girl yeah I was
expecting it to be all boy and it 105mm
girls my thought therapy which is nice
the items you are noticed the divide
really until I got into the industry
when I was working advertising and then
I started to go to events yeah and then
I actually had the comment that was the
first time the comment you don't look
like you should be a developer came up
and I was like what down in myself like
what's wrong with me
how should I know yeah I always put that
down to perhaps looking young yeah I
know I look young yeah but then you know
even though it shouldn't be the case in
a young or old or whatever doesn't
matter people are into whatever they're
into I guess the world is becoming more
way from the old miner yeah I should be
intimidating like yeah there are
definitely more guys and girls and are
cool but they're all lovely and they do
okay yeah there is a the majority are
lovely I mean there's no one that comes
up to us and says you know you can't
meet again no one does that and maybe
it's just it's just in our own head and
you're like yeah there's so much talk
about it but the only thing you know is
like you should definitely not have
flashing in the workplace or in the
education I think that's that's the only
thing that might be a slight issue but
that's yummy
we're in university they're young
they're young
yeah I don't Wow I don't think that
would be the case in the workplace only
you'd marry someone as well I guess
you'd like know what the case laws and
everything and then they'll be like okay
cool like you me cool Authority that
takes time doesn't it would you have any
advice to any girl he wants to go into
oh boy go into industry or today or into
the industry
yeah that's not coming to you nothing I
shall be for another video
I think he'll farted chase your dream
your point was quite relevant making
games is completely different playing
games yeah and once you make again it is
so much hard work that goes in here
this is especially if you are doing a
course like ours which is very broad and
tries to help you understand all aspects
of making games sort of modeling the
animation the texturing the coding the
drawing absolutely everything it's so
much to learn and do that you don't even
get I play games and oh no and then you
realize when you do play games like how
much effort goes into inaudible respond
over oh yeah you can do a little bit
although also I find that I'm actually
appreciating game yeah yeah all that
that texture is so cool that physics is
another page word of duty like a couple
of months after we started studying I
call my girls like all the effort that's
gone into this you realize we have a new
understanding and a new respect for the
game developers also another thing that
I find in the game industry it's harder
to get into well I think it's harder to
get noticed get into always like media
advertising even film there are so many
kind of internship skiing yeah and like
companies are constantly different
forerunners I looked at not as there was
an internship but it was a job and
obviously I don't have enough experience
yeah I just applied for the job yeah
there's like barely anything that was
the only one I found I was looking for
an internship actually and everyone I
wanted people weren't like a full time
person or it was like you all had to
know all this stuff about like Maya not
all these different program that's why
are at a moment online nope not doing it
because it is about learning
like you cannot start from somewhere do
you guys that you want to work in the
game industry well I'm unsure
like I knew but my dream job would just
be modeling 3d props I think rather than
actually need to go to that watching
industry I guess yeah just doing that
would be like my dream at the moment by
publishers and my lipsticks might cut
I'm so indecisive for next year is last
year really so ah what about you I would
love to do flying in through the
environment but it's all else fails I
want to be a chef really yeah
all else fails barman offsuit wipers
well your brownies my night you already
made in brownies I'd love to just work
from where I can be already experimental
because I just wanted to learn new
things I just wanted to learn new things
to tell stories with so it's not even
necessarily being in the game world
however the more I'm learning how to
make a game I really do think this is
the industry that I love because I love
film but I just love being able to think
outside the box and just knowing code
and how to make interactive environments
and like 3d models and stuff that you
can interact with them using the
Internet of Things but mixes that and
it's just so much that you can learn
there's so many different things and
it's constantly evolving and which you
can do it really excites me
but then you're like I wouldn't be happy
just being in a big company and we okay
today you're modeling about it Mike that
were you for me it's like thinking about
like the possibilities of like what
could happen if you used all the small
things in the right ways and and what
new coding language would bring in new
elements and like what could really push
the platform above a bar so I guess a
game designer but I know that's really
freaking difficult to be so I've got to
choose the most difficult one tonight
thanks to you and you're very motivated
very busy you will get there I think
together mm-hmm okay well you're very
like why don't we gonna start our own
company here we can see why not
it's definitely a mess you do anything
anyway I just really wanted you guys to
know who I was working with when making
the Google VR game because these girls
are just really talented like honestly
couldn't have done it without them and
they don't even like coding so I'm like
yes it's all it's all mine so yeah I
just think it's really really nice but I
found a team that I can work with when
making these games and we'll be working
will we will we we working together next
you okay I was going to get dumped them
no no I'll be working together next year
oh yes this is something we need to tell
you this have like the whole you know
one week yeah to make again
yes I mean start brainstorming so what
we're making another game and I will be
showing the gain that we made with you
by Halloween of this yeah yeah this um
yeah so you'll see what we've been
working on but yeah I just really wanted
you to know who these lovely ladies are
I will leave their links in the
description below so check them out and
yeah have a lovely day or evening bye oh
my god I love my cheeks ago oh I feel
like I don't too much so you are a bit
Randall you're very warm and that wasn't
bad a floor would be nice yeah